autre affaire c'est aujourd'hui que
s'est ouvert le procès du journaliste
militante aboaf accusé d'avoir posté un
message insultant envers la police hier
à linda kebab en juin 2020 sur twitter
il l'avait notamment qualifié et
d'arabes de service le procès qui a
commencé vers 13h30 au tribunal être
correctionnel de paris avait pour but de
juger le journaliste pour injure
publique à raison de l'origine tawaf et
bénéficie de nombreux soutiens linda
kebab de son côté attend des
explications concrètes du journaliste
au regard de ce que j'ai lu sur la
convocation ce sont les termes arabes de
service qui sont associés justement une
injure donc en tant que policier pour
moi une injure je vais réitérer le type
d'injures que j'ai eu à traiter au cours
de ma carrière mais je suis pas sûr que
dans les mots arabes et services je
puisse moi même identifié une injure
écoutez si des personnes présentes dans
la salle s'identifient comme victimes de
ces propos et considère qu' aujourd'hui
être traitée d' arabes et qui voient une
injure ce n'est pas à mon opinion c'est
ce que je vais faire valoir devant le
tribunal si ce n'est que je pense que la
maladresse de taha abou hafs finalement
lui à la conduit à comment dire à tenir
ces propos à mon sens
pour moi le jir est que l'accusation
porte plus contre l'institution
policière au regard de la façon dont
elle traite ses éléments issus de la
diversité
plus que de linda kebab qui à mon sens
est peut être victime malgré elle
justement de l'usaj que fait
l'institution policière de ses origines
de sa personne quand on veut éviter le
faux et le débat on va sur la forme et
qui on va titiller les textes en
laissant croire que en fait ce procès
n'a pas les deux lettres et pourtant et
pourtant il avait dit qu'il avait hâte
de s'expliquer pas qui c'est